estelle farges sl bonjour vous êtes à à
senlis dans l'oise comment se passe la
reprise pour cette librairie si vous
trouvez actuellement
eh bien elle est salvatrice en cette
réouverture de rock vous en doutez je me
trouve avec julien burnat qui est le
propriétaire cette librairie
alors merci beaucoup de répondre à nos
questions où on a vu tout à l'heure
l'adjoint au maire qui est venu déposer
un kit qu'est ce qu'il ya dans ce kit
alors c'est un clip de redémarrage où on
a quelques masques un peu de gel il ya
aussi du des adhésifs pour mettre au sol
qu'on peut avoir et puis une affichette
apposée sur la vitrine pour dire
parce qu'il en est des mesures
sanitaires alors justement comment ça va
se passer ici je vois qu'il ya un petit
flacon de gel hydro alcoolique qui a été
déposée à l'entrée comment est ce que
vous allez faire pour garantir la
sécurité des clients ici l'idée c'est
que les gens se lave les mains en
rentrant comme on a pris l'habitude de
le faire dans les autres magasins ceux
qui sont restés ouverts
il se lave les mains on va essayer de ne
pas être plus de 3 dans la librairie à
chaque fois ensemble et puis moi je vais
m'assurer que tout se soit bien
désinfecter avec une désinfection du
plan de la caisse et puis et puis le sol
le soir vont évidemment à vendent avant
de partir et puis la porte reste ouverte
donc on n'a pas à toucher la poignée
donc toi bien ri ce niveau là
après deux mois de fermeture dans quel
état d'esprit êtes vous aujourd'hui on
est content je revenais en fait on
s'aperçoit que ça nous avait manqué de
voir des gens déjà comme j'imagine
paroles de français et puis nous qui
sommes vraiment contact des gens tous
les jours normalement là ça faisait
vraiment étrange d'être chez soi sans
voir personne sans client alors on vous
attend bien sûr on est impatient de vous
revoir merci beaucoup je viens burda
voile à doha pour cette librairie dans
l'oise où toutes les conditions en sont
réunies pour accueillir les clients en
toute sécurité loin qui je le rappelle
est en rouge sur la carte du
déconfinement la l'oise qui était le
premier foyer de l'épidémie en france
estelle farges en direct de senlis dans
l'oise merci pour toutes ces précisions